je prends une telle main dans le sac
bravo aux annan fait partie des
adhérents de l'association à se régaler
cela lui donne le droit de venir faire
ses courses à l'épi du rotois re
installé à guyancourt cette épicerie
participative propose plus de 90
produits
on a des produits de producteurs locaux
avec des produits bons et saints on a
vraiment là la traçabilité du produit de
la création à la livraison a ici des
sardines des bières locales du miel ou
encore des conserves
tous les produits sont issus du circuit
court ce qui permet de les retrouver des
tarifs avantageux
le principe est simple les adhérents
font leurs courses en ligne viennent les
récupérer les mardis et vendredis soir
ainsi que le samedi matin
en échange ils doivent donner deux
heures de leur temps par mois il n'y a
pas un zéro n'y a pas d des chefs de
rayon où on est tous au même niveau
on va aller chacun notre tour ou qui se
dévouent pour aller chercher chez les
producteurs ou prendre contact pour
chercher nouveaux produits ou la mise en
rayon ou le réassort pour l'instant 35
personnes ont adhéré à ce concept dont
l'objectif est également de créer du
lien social
le fait d'avoir une adhésion et de
former un groupe où chacun participe je
trouve que c'est très intéressant et que
ça crée du lien aussi au niveau du
voisinage convivialité manger mieux et
pour moins cher voici les valeurs
défendues par l'épi du rotois requis
devrait bientôt enrichir le concept